I think what we're starting to get a
real sense of now is what led up to the
anger the couple feel about the way they
were handled and treated by both the
press and the palace and the
relationship between the two we sort of
start episode four on The Fallout from
their wedding how everything was going
brilliantly their first Royal tour in
Australia in October 2018 and they were
so popular at that point with the public
that members inside the palace started
to feel threatened and that's where we
hired Harry talking about how their
popularity came at a price to other
members of the royal family and that's
when these negative stories these
negative headlines started to emerge be
it things like the way Megan would hold
her baby bump compared to how Kate held
hers or whether the similar style of
dress they were wearing was compared
favorably to Kate but negatively to to
Megan Harry speaks about how there was
this dirty game of constant briefing
this weird acceptance he says of leaking
and planting how you'd get one member of
the same comms team having had a
negative story about one of their
principals one of their members of the
royal family then turning to the media
and trading negative information about
someone else's member of the royal
family he said they'd seen this trading
in their father's office and that him
and William had made this agreement they
would never do the same and this is
where Harry gets very personal I think
with Prince William for the first time
he then goes on to say to see his
brother's office copy the very same
thing they'd promised the two of us
would never do he said it was
heartbreaking and as he thinks Williams
office started to negatively brief
against him there's also a lot of detail
about the leaking of that letter Megan
wrote to her father Thomas Markle a big
court case followed that Harry makes it
very clear he believes that Megan's
miscarriage was caused by the negative
press coverage at the time that the
pressure that caused directly related
and had the impact of her having that
miscarriage so lots of of big
Revelations here no comments at the
moment from the palace though